okay so first game playing the net
National master from Brazil
uh
let's place the ceiling
let's stick with my usual
we might transpose into taimana
okay I hope the move don't the move
sounds to be too loud
wow so already allowing D5
yeah it's weird to develop the bishop so
early to E3 because now D4 is a threat
I mean why could maybe like take take
and then play D4
um but then that allows C4 C4 B4 but
really already looks Pleasant for black
like even though that white has
three minor pieces developed
I have more pawns developed pawns are
good at forking minor pieces
so it's a question after D4 do I play B4
or C4
or something else
I mean this is also possible
Queen E7 you know Queen e795
if B4
I think just C4 B4 can come later
but still playable for white White's
gonna play like Bishop E2
I imagine white will not Castle
queenside
I'm very much prepared to attack on the
queen side
um
I could take that
and then put the bishop
ah there's a funny line
how do I make it work
take
b492
okay so one funny line
I forgot we could take with this Pawn
which might be coming
yeah okay I have to play this oh Bishop
B4 as well
yeah maybe bishop B4
getting ready for 97. I want to keep my
Bishop along this diagonal
yeah for some reason I was only
calculating F takes and then Queen H4
ideas
I really doubt why it's gonna Castle
Queen inside
now I'm maybe threatening this
okay considering Queen A5
this is more flexible
hey Eric good luck smile my name is
[ __ ]
or my name is Jeff
interesting spelling of Jeff
opponent offers a draw
I want to play Knights
and this move looks interesting
not a five
it also looks risky but
because I'm accepting the fact I'm not
gonna castle if I'm preparing D4 which
looks like a pretty venomous threat
okay Rook D1 Bishop E6
if this I'm banking on Queen H4 which
should be fine
ready to play Rook C8
the bishop can't really stay on this
diagonal like I guess white could play
uh Bishop B4 we trade
and then like Castle
oh Bishop e4v Trail I played this and
then Knight E3
okay take Bishop B6 d494
looks really close to being really good
I think I'll just Castle first he might
send a pickle here because if castling
then I take in Bishop B6
foreign
is just over 2600
okay positions Pleasant time is Pleasant
Bishop Matthew is a good move but now I
can take
probably go for the sign
D4
uh but now what to do
Queen H4 maybe just H6
H6 castling
not sure what to do I shouldn't be
taking too much time
I have Bishop A5
move just didn't even come to mind
okay
so I got funny Pawns
well it has annoying pawns though
foreign
s are more menacing
is this free
wait that's
just take here first let's take care
first
foreign
okay
that was uh
that was a tricky game
wasn't so easy
welcome to Canada Canada oh it's good to
be in Canada Canada
I'm in Toronto for the global chess.com
championships which officially start
tomorrow
but today is kind of the what do we call
it preparation day media day
yeah Canada
[Music]
Oh Canada
I should write a parody song
to Oh Canada
that's called oh no my Canada oh I'm
playing preggy also thank you Eve
Anastasia
appreciate the rain
I played kruggy and Abu Dhabi
a couple months ago
he beat me pretty convincingly
okay let's play B5 that's a tricky move
order
so he's avoiding like Main
line Catalan
but um
yeah I played this line a bunch in Blitz
Knight fd7 is very typical
I make sure this Knight control C6
if I move the wrong Knight to D7 there
would be Knight C6
thank you smashing in
gifting to Eve Anastasia
if you're just joining it's titled
Tuesday
I'm in a new habitat in Toronto
uh E4 wow
so first thing that comes to mind is
takes
okay I could start my take and then C6
or D4
oh really
impossible can I play Knight D7
wow
so a weird line
I want to trap the bishop like Knight C4
is kind of interesting
okay this is this is getting tricky this
could be just bad for me but
I'm essentially trying to call the bluff
but I don't know yet if it was actually
a bluff
if takes I play Knight B6 I think but
then A5 I missed
I mean the general plan is like after I
lose a rook I'll be down in exchange but
I have C6 to try and trap the bishop
and Knight B6 will hopefully win the
bishop in some cases
um
that's actually a question because I can
also take with the pawn
[Music]
um
but yeah I will take with Pawn this is
not my first like idea of a
um not like the smooth then the bishop
escapes so probably Queen C7
Queen C7 Bishop four Bishop D6
uh but that might be five
if
I think I kind of messed up
I mean there's E5 no E5 doesn't work
yeah just a lot of Bishop for
I think I actually have to go for this
line
they have
of
me I originally missed Knight B5 and now
it's
it's probably just really bad for black
I'll try and fight I mean
there's still Bishop A6 ideas
it's a funny position
so what's my threat Bishop A6 Knight t7
but then Bishop C6
wow
so if I take the Rook
foreign
Bishop D6 okay
I wonder if I play another five
yeah The Rook comes to C1
I mean I can't really stop
like even the queen trade
Rook c1's coming regardless
okay I have one idea so after a rook
I've seen one I played G5
this way I'm gonna like force a trade or
Force the bishop to retreat
the goal is to actually exploit the
light squares later the bishop is so
disconnected from the King side
Ah that's a good move
um
let's play F6
yeah the C file battery it's not
pleasant
I don't even know what my plan is
to hold on for dear life
A7 is falling
I guess my plan is to Checkmate somehow
but that's gonna be really difficult
I just need my queen to get in
like pawnage three Queen G2
how difficult can that be
oh there's Rook a or okay six
not quite working
so Rook C7 I take on D4
okay
three seconds
oh no White's promoting
oh no my king
oh
that was closer than I would have
expected
like the center
it did open up but why I think White had
everything under control
yeah I don't think there are even any
opportunities for tricks towards the end
good game though opponent played well we
can quickly look at the like this
interesting moment
I don't think I've ever encountered this
move
yeah maybe had this position like once
or twice
oh White's better here
after ed5
oh but it's not so simple engines at low
depth
opponent just played
like the top moves so we actually follow
the Top Line
D5
yeah Queen C7 was a mistake
so it's close to a quality after 96.
but very tricky
there's a question duck question mark
I did bring ducks with me to Toronto
I smuggled them through customs
I didn't declare them where are the
Ducks though okay let me find the Ducks
I found a singular duck
hey autofocus is working it is
beautifully photogenic duck there's a
giant Duck in Toronto I did not know
that maybe I'll try and find it
okay new game playing
ronsdale play D4
how many people are watching from
Vietnam
Vietnam is the birthplace of Pho right
okay
I have this opening a ton in title
Tuesday
jobava London
most people play H5 there's different
moves though
C6 is a move
yeah this is still some
some offbeat Theory
um I mean Bishop E5
Bishop E5 just leads to funny Pawn
structure takes things and then
eventually F4
all Castle queenside
we might see like F6
or that move it's a good move
if I take
the taking looks reasonable actually
and most of my pawns will be on
darkspurs
which really complements light story
Bishop
very basic plan now of um can now
threatening the knights
interesting let's start with Rook G1
maybe the plan Isn't So basic
I'll play Queen D1
I'm gonna start with a double up
I might be sacking The Exchange in the
not too distant future
tomorrow
so I could already like take and then
sack
I'll start with this
okay now if I taken sack
hmm
not too afraid of A3 just B3
and there's a plan to maneuver the
Knight to D3 and then E5
this also stops Pawn B4
so very long term I want to play King B1
Knight C1 Knight T3 Knight E5 take take
take take and then assuming this Rook
like moves off f8 Knight F7 checkmate
like I'm already planning my
uh
it's like kind of planning your college
plans as a five-year-old
like you're never too young to think
ahead
the training Queens kind of actually it
doesn't really ruin my plans
okay we'll trade Queens I still have the
same time
I just really like the prospect of 93
I mean this move would force a trade
and then the Knight can't come to D3
I'm also realizing there's a cool idea
to play B4
okay I'm switching my life plans
no longer going to college
and I pursue the YouTubers streamer
route
there's so many parallels to chess in
real life
and plans will change along the way
just have to
play the position that you're given
I really like this position like this is
a very kind of long-term
positional grind but white has full
control over everything
um mainly the A3 Pawn is gonna be the
target
uh I take that
maybe I take it
oh there's a funny line
does it work though
I think it works
so the funny line is Knight G7 Knight G3
it looks like I'm allowing my Rook to be
trapped
um if H6 I would have taken and I think
I can still take
although maybe I can't
the King Pawn ending is not winning for
me
unless it is we take six
no I don't think it is
each six of threads
okay I think H6 is losing so I think I
can just go and tape upon so if H6 I
take take Knight H5 King F7
let's try this again draw accurate
arrows
so Knight H5 king of seven I take if
King takes very important move H5
is that just a draw though
that might just be a draw
oh am I losing
King B3 King there
I forgot I don't have H5
okay I don't have time to calculate
okay this gets crazy actually
look at this Pond breakthrough C4
oh
I'm gonna be down a lot of Pawns
B5 Maybe
wait
so I got the first move
I'm not down to any Pawns
wait what a crazy position
King F2 I forced a queen trade
so I want to win the Apon
that's a risky move
no I just got mated
oh I forgot about Queen B2 I had to take
the pawn
no what to do
oh that was the wrong move order that's
such a nice position too
what happened to all my life plans
yeah maybe I should just start with uh
King D3 there's no reason to
like go for Rook G5
yeah for some reason I assume the King
was gonna land on F7 or F6 and I'd have
H5
which maybe still is drawn
because the king can just run over and
even if I win the pawn
I don't know if I can win this
yeah there's just no breakthrough
after game though
dc7 asking what was the chess book you
recommended on Audible
I've actually recommended a lot of Chess
books on Audible
um or a lot of Chess books in these um
I'll do these like YouTube audible
Integrations
as audible will sponsor some videos
the most recent video I recommended
think like a monk
by Jay Shetty
in the past I've recommended chess
Queens by Jen shahadi
art of learning by Josh waitskin
foreign
I believe in miracles
the story of Tani adawumi
is one of my favorites
um
all the wrong moves by Sasha Chapin All
these books I've mentioned in these uh
YouTube Integrations
the list probably goes on too
there's a book by Jonathan Rosen
his name is similar to mine that's felt
differently
B4
just played B6
is preventing this I mean white was
threatening to trap the bishop
so I just wanna
uh develop
not lose material
maybe go for this idea
rookies
yeah this is some slow play
playing slow in jazz has a couple
meanings it's like moving slowly where
you take a lot of time
and then your clock runs low but then
there's also like making slow moves at
um
maybe aren't the most confrontational
okay position is very solid now
relatively harmonious setup
put the Rooks in the center probably go
for this maneuver
yeah I've only had real duck once in my
life
um
back in June in Vegas
Andrea boats has offered me 10 gifted
Subs to eat
some duck
but then I I still haven't received my
reward
I'll have to be patient
okay
if white allows I'll play C4 but okay
uh maybe this move
D4 ideas
Bishop B8
I like Bishop B8
yeah the whole interaction was caught on
videos so maybe
someday the the video will be uncovered
I was part of the Vegas Vlog I played D4
now takes takes
okay
I'm up almost a minute on the clock
um I'm playing very aggressively here
but these Bishops
these Bishops are more effective than
White's Bishops
yeah do I go to small claims court
or a small duck court
I played most of this game like
with my mind on completely different
things in the game itself but this is
going pretty well I mean F3 is attacked
and I don't know how light defends I
guess
why doesn't defend
so
that's interesting though I have to be
careful
hmm
you might as well take take again
no this move
I'm not taking the Rook the light is
stronger than the Rook
I do have to be aware of uh counter play
so now this move
oh no my knight
yeah this is attack this is attacked
this is attacked
this is still attacks
is it just made in one
that's main one
that took me more than one second to
find
I found it eventually I mean there were
so many moves there
I guess Knight D2 is made in two
okay worked out
the horsies were very powerful
so I'm back at fifty percent
trying to regain my 2600 plus rating
handful of players with 4 out of four
where's furuja
okay not playing frusia playing someone
from Peru
a female Master I'll play D4
London opening time
thank you
yeah when the C5 is played on move two
it enables the early Queen B6 it
sometimes just transposes to the main
lines if D5 or E6 is played
uh there's G6 in this position
I mean these are
oh there's Knight T5
Knight D5 is also playable
opponent's taking a lot of time in the
opening though
yeah just holding the structure together
this line looks scary at first like with
black having a lot of initiative but
um the structure is actually pretty
solid
I might want to go for C4 although
maybe not
let's take it slow working one
as a question how I developed the Knight
because the lights tied down to the pawn
C4 kind of weaken
yeah it would weaken the d-pawn
so I might go for Knight A3
okay this is kind of a threat
maybe this move
challenging the bishop preventing the E4
thanks for all the nice content you're
the best
oh thank you
DJ rnng
Queen F4 Queen F4 looks playable
the queen is on a slightly precarious
Square
but okay 92
trying to make sense of this position
E5 wow if I take
wow
I'm not sure if this is a bluff or like
fully calculated from Black
I'm trying to call the bluff
it's backfired in previous games
I want a pawn
yeah there's compensation here
Bishop C2
I do have to be very very careful
the back rank is vulnerable Knight's
still not developed
but I'm controlling like all these
squares on the D file
and I mean black has a discovery but the
problem is the knights tie down to
defending the bishop
that's a move maybe rookie one
ah but then Knight D5
what if I play
I play H3
up on time which is good
you have Knight T5 I just take it and
then take the bishop
um
it's interesting
I think I'll play 93. some guy really
Knight D5 Queen F3 takes takes and then
the bishop is just really stable on D4
I think that's enough compensation
if it's not enough conversation it's it
seems like an easier position to play
and that's important for
time scrambles
the Dork stores are really weak now
ah there's Queen F4
not the end of the world
yeah The Bishop's just a rock
it's so hard for black to remove
now it's a question if I can never get
my queen to G7
hmm
Rook T1
G3
that looks weakening but
maybe there's some Merit
wow
playing with fire here
[Music]
this should be good
that's still tricky
queen f8 queen G5
okay
I think I'm threatening rookie one
not sure though
it probably doesn't work
okay now rookie one
oh no my Rook if takes I take on F6
ah
foreign
there we go
still not over
okay there we go
plenty of time
okay
not an easy game
a tricky uh tricky position
so I'm three out of five
yeah interesting opening
very tense position
I think E5 was maybe a good classical
choice
and black eventually did win material
maybe I missed something at some point
to blackout Bishop D1 on move 18.
yeah I was I was actually thinking about
the D1 it's an interesting move
uh maybe back a move
yeah Bishop D1 I might have to play 93
and allow the trade
uh but then age five
yeah maybe it would lead to something
similar where I do sack The Exchange
that's a cool move
Knight C3 on move 25.
oh Knight C3
talktikos
you have Knight C3
if I can't save the bishop then this is
probably really bad
if Knight C3 was played neither I would
take play this position
I have two minor pieces for the queen
positional Queen sacrifice
because yeah after it takes takes it's
Down The Exchange
okay things were a missless game
but life goes on so I'm back on the plus
score
playing the Zev
not quite bereave
I'm speaking with London
staying in my comfort zone usually
entitled Tuesdays I don't mix up mix up
the openings too much especially against
like high rate players
foreign
acceptable
usually light weights until a bishop G7
is played
but
I mean in the case that black allows me
I take on f8 and I take away castling
rights
if the queen comes to H6 I also take
away casting rights
[Music]
um
leaving tension
maybe now I can take
yeah now The Rook is a bit stuck
um
this might seem crazy but I'm
considering cows and queen side here
it is weird to Castle into Block's Pawn
storm
if I take take
Rook D6 in the end
Rook d65
let's close
I really shouldn't trade Queens that's
against principle
okay
wow each five
so G5
something like F4
I mean visually it looks really good but
it still takes work
Bishop H3
or F4
F4
the Knight wants to develop
generally I'm not scared of B3 because
it takes an A3
or takes in Queen takes
interesting
maybe I can take
take ones and play F5
there's also about five immediately
B3
or A3 B3
I mean I could also ignore it but
play B3
yeah that's a small concern this B2
Square
but I think black has bigger issues here
I might play Knight G3 of black olives
okay never mind
yeah these pawns are pretty menacing
F6
I think long term locks just gonna be
shut in
shut in or shut out
shut out from the rest of the board but
surely not the king's side
okay now I can take yeah I think I'll
just go into an end game
and black should be paralyzed
like takes in Rook D7
like the Knight can't move
foxes resigns oh that was a nice finish
yeah Bishop C4 was coming it's um
like if vac would want to defend Rook H7
but uh it was complete paralysis
and it was pretty because it's equal
material
anyway uh I'm four out of six after kind
of a slow start I started one out of
three
but I'm on a three game winning streak
have you ever thought about starting a
podcast
I've thought about it a little bit
it would take a lot of commitment
and I'm already juggling juggling a lot
of things but maybe someday
having a podcast is a great excuse to
just reach out to people that inspire
you and have great conversations with
them so
um I like the idea of like
of just having a show to
absorb Knowledge from various people and
then share that knowledge with the world
I mean these days are so many great
podcasts
it's it's hard to keep up with
everything
I should say I meant to say so many
great chess podcasts but just so many
great podcasts in general too is there
any non-chess podcasts you'd like to
recommend
my favorite podcast for a while was um
it was called reply all
they actually ended the show but it was
a like there were over 100 episodes it
was part of gimlet media
um so many great stories a lot about
like Tech and internet and
um
yeah it was not chess related
um
I want to go for a Cambridge Springs
let's play this line
I've been working on a chess course
recently it's actually one of the
reasons I've I've stopped like I kind of
took a break from
posting on YouTube so I've been
recording course content
and it's all about this opening
uh A3 I don't think I've covered yet
I know C5 is the main break
maybe I can play C5 right away
like the main move is Bishop D3
that was maybe not the best
advertisement for my future course
I think I've already botched the opening
but I'm getting the bishop I already
have the bishop here which is nice this
is going to be participating in November
what is that
I just dropped a pawn I have to focus
ah
and I'm giving up the disappear I have
King takes
how bad is King takes
it looks really bad
but otherwise I just lose a pawn so I
think I have I have to at least try this
oh this looks so bad
Queen D6 no
Queen's E4 Queen C4
when z492
I mean at least I prevent castling
I'm trying to make it so okay oh I lost
a queen
oh I lost in 14 moves
oh I'm so sad now
oh what to do
okay let me let me at least give a sneak
preview to my course
and I'll share
and this is actually part of like the
process of
of learning a new opening because
there's so many new lines I'm learning
in Cambridge Springs
and um part of learning a new opening is
playing it and very often you'll
encounter lines that you don't know and
you'll run into trouble quickly
that's kind of what just happened to me
so I have a study
um anyway this study is not complete the
chapters aren't even like labeled so
well
but I have a whole thing here
on the Cambridge Springs
and
I Do cover this line
it's funny
so in my annotations I say this is a
relatively harmless move that is one of
the most commonly played moves in the
Lee chest database I think just overall
too and
I didn't cover A3 because if we if we
look like
another thing when it comes to learning
openings is you want to prioritize like
the most likely responses so Bishop D3
it's the most played move
but of course there's different branches
so A3 is the fifth most popular
played seven percent of the time on Lee
chess
but it makes sense because it prevents
Bishop B4
nine games in Masters database black
actually already scores pretty well
yeah C5 I think was just it was too soon
yeah 94. I didn't play Knight E4 because
Queen C2 ah but Queen c2i Bishop B4
I could have just followed basic ideas
in Cambridge Springs like this is ideal
setup I got the Queen Bishop and Knight
and there's two pins a pawn is pinned
and the Knight is pinned
okay and so A3
yeah E3 is not really uh
a scary move to deal with
Dave sorry for C1
ah Rook C1 we can take
and then if Rook takes
wow that's a cool trap Bishop takes A3
ah
I don't think I've seen this trap before
that's such nice geometry
look at this triangle
so it looks like two things are
attacking E3 but the pawn is tied down
to the rook and The Rook is pinned to
the king
so the only move for white that isn't
losing because bc3 loses a pawn
only move is Queen D2
G6 G6 is interesting just being kind of
the bishop
later go for C5
okay looks solid
anyway I'm super excited uh hopefully
release like these files soon uh I began
the process of recording videos
but um Cambridge Springs has been
it's been an opening that I've wanted to
research
for a while now
because it's just it's not the most
common and it has a lot of Venom I think
it's relatively simple to learn
and all this I got so many questions as
um like from amateur players what to do
against D4 what to do against Queen's
Gambit
so it's a good reply to Queen's Gambit
yeah it was a painful loss but a very
valuable lesson and usually games like
this you should
like games that you lose so early in the
opening you should make an effort to
um to look closer at what can be
improved is the webcam getting dark yeah
the sun's going down but
what to do playing Cree core
so I'm four out of seven
playing up again
good luck to Creek or
we played a good number of times
see my score
wow we played 21 times
only drawn three games
he's beat me 12 times I've been him six
times
uh let's play have a good time in
Toronto
oh thank you biblio penguin
G3 okay
uh Bishop D7 first
I honestly don't know the lines here
I hope I can under E5 I don't think I
did because there'd be responses
thank you Noah constrictor
I mean queen A5 looks kind of standard
six hope you enjoy your stay
thank you thank you thank you Dr diazam
yes now I can take and play 95.
I do have to be careful that the Knight
doesn't get trapped but it's not in
danger
Queen B6 now
pressuring B2
maybe Knight C4 will come soon Rook B1 I
have Bishop F5
this already looks like very pleasant
um Queen B3
yeah I want to play Knight T3
but then we just trade
Queen C5
there's quite a six which is interesting
just avoiding the queen Trade It sets up
some Bishop A4
but it also helps control these light
squares
so the queen and Knight actually
coordinate well it also ties down the
Rook
so one idea might be Knight D3
like Knight D3 Rook D1 Bishop A4 or
Knight C5 and there's going to be a lot
of targets
okay Knight D3 I think wins a pawn
if I wouldn't be two then I probably win
C3
almost chopping The Rook there
okay not quite winning C3
um
95
the night's just going on a rampage but
still want to be accurate
there's Queen D3 look at this move
simply attacking the pawn
I don't think white can really defend
maybe bishop D2
Bishop D2 Knight C4
foreign
probably B6
Knight D3
I think this is okay I'll put the Rook
on A3
in the event of
uh-huh
this move
foreign
I'm looking for a clear plan
not super simple
okay
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh it's not meat though ah
that's what I do
I dropped all my Pawns
foreign
okay
I missed a free rook but I attacked the
bishop so it was confusing
oh wow
oh it just happened there
okay
oh yeah it was such like a a dominating
position too
I just lost so many pawns I should have
played Rook G6
I just blamed that my e-pawn was
attacked I hang a bishop too
so many things were hung that game
high level chess
but not really wow I'm gaining reading
somehow
5 out of eight yeah lots of things were
missed
and the opening was so nice maybe the
Early Middle game
like once I got this structure and
there's so much initiative on the queen
side okay I'll take it uh
uh well that was around eight
hey we have another break
oh I saw um
I saw a goose in real life recently
didn't have the chance to play duck
chess with the goose
but I took a walk the other day
oh about a week ago I I was sitting
outside the chess club having a smoothie
and there is some someone that came up
and recognized me
and showed me that they had
look at this they had a
Red Rubber Duck
it looked like a poisonous duck
not to be messed with
but uh yeah the Ducks are spreading
and then about a couple weeks ago this
was the closest I got to playing
[Music]
chess with ducks
people can see the Ducks there
but uh
yeah the weather in St Louis is still
warm enough for
ducks to be there
have you considered bird watching
I've not only considered bird watching
I've
are taken in bird watching recently
or at least duck and geese watching
okay so I'm five out of eight I'll
probably play some Highway the player
next game
I think that was my first upset of the
tournament like my first upset victory
rather than upset loss
something happened with the sound there
duh do people hear that yeah
something's wrong with my sound
uh
oh I think you're trying to learn
okay
I think the sound should be normal for
people but my speakers just got messed
up
I get hacked
or does it sound weird for people too
uh I don't have time to troubleshoot
but something's off yeah sorry about
that
as long as my uh my my mic or my voice
sounds fine
it might just be with TTS
uh yeah this is Mainline
what's the line here
seven
axis
I actually don't remember the line
I may have already gone wrong
um
F6
maybe it's still okay
a five I take and then put the Knight
back
if H5 then I can go to E3
I can't quite win the pongs I get forked
and just Castle
yeah my opponent was clearly prepared
most people don't know to play a CD4
okay this move looks weird but I'm
anticipating some lines where I might
take back with the F Pawn
or not
I really want to take
hmm
and maybe we'll have a quiet game
and just trade off the minor pieces
okay at least now I can maybe play F3
soon
ah the sound is still weird I don't know
what happened but thank you Andrew
I'll probably just mute alerts during
the game
uh
uh interesting
play this
[ __ ] let's play this first
I want to play this in nh4 Knight F7
then take on F6
um
because I have to take
I think I just allowed H5 there
okay so now I'm threatening H4
there's some nice alignment the queen
and king
do
I just missed that
oh how bad is this
I'm losing a piece or losing the
exchange
um
before
it might be three probably might be
three
it's not over but it's not great
I'll put the Rook on E2
wait so if I take what's the point
Ah that's the point I can't take on D5
nice move
uh
Queen B1
Queen F1
that's so uncomfortable
[Music]
okay Knight C4 I take and take on D5
but no rookie one
there were no time to calculate
this might just be losing I calculated
rookie one Queen F2 Queen C4
I do defend H4 Queen G1 King G3
but it's really close to losing
so if Rook G1 I have Queen C7
if I have time maybe Knight C5
I was probably just waiting for black
somehow
C5
and this is hope at least
Queen D6 F4
duh
yeah
uh B4 was a panic move
Queen C6 was a good practical decision
I had to move the queen maybe there is
still hope
uh just not enough time
I kind of blundered what should I
blunder
also yeah I was a little bit distracted
with the sound
um I don't even know how to troubleshoot
don't be upset I guess now I just have
demon speakers yeah
there's no filter
I might just have to restart the
computer it's concerning though
when I wonder if I did something like
when this happened though
yeah there's no okay okay here we go
uh this is round ten so this is a
penultimate round
playing solo chess I think I've reached
the point where if I if if I encounter
E4 I'll go for Stafford if I encounter
D4 I'll go for my new course
and if I encounter no moves at all
maybe I'll win by forfeit
are you doing photography for the event
I am yeah yeah today was actually a kind
of busy day
there are a lot of player interviews I
got a behind the scenes look at like all
the
um
like the whole venue and the setup it's
a really cool setup
and I will have photos to share at a
later point
okay opponent gambiting their time
yeah I have spent the last couple weeks
like working on this um it's essentially
a repertoire against D4
and I'm trying to be thorough with it
I'm trying to have it be appealing to
players like basically from 1200 to 2200
there we go okay
so upon giving me time odds
uh hey we have a Stafford
hopefully my opponent didn't spend the
first 90 seconds researching how to
refute the Stacker
it's good that they're thinking here
though
is this Peru oh this is Peru again
I played an FM from Peru earlier too
okay so this is a the main critical line
of Safford the so-called magical line
G3 is most played
now there's a few moves
hitting F2
there we go
I mean I've Barely Used any time
this line is fun when um like when the
pun takes a lot of time and I can just
Blitz out
analysis
ah Bishop F4
[Music]
I take
I've looked at this recently
93 Knight G2
I remember the point is I stack on G2
engine will give plus four for whites
but there's a cool idea
I think I have to play Knight G2
yeah the cool idea is Bishop H3
and then C5 I'm pretty sure this is
still prep
and there's enough attackers on C5 where
it's kind of interesting
C4
so I am down the piece though and that's
unfortunate but I can now trap The Rook
and that's fortunate
but the unfortunate thing is I'm still
down a lot of material and I don't think
I want to take the Rook just yet
like maybe Queen's like casting Knight
A3 is coming though
opponent has 24 seconds so
I just have to find ways to make things
tricky
taking takes I mean taking on each two
is possible
maybe I can play C6
C6 G6
okay there is one funny line I see
so I want to open the D file get the
rook in
opponent of course wants to trade Queens
which I would rather not do
take take
actually trading might be okay
wow
foreign
I don't want to simplify
but each
ah
should not have allowed that
okay
this could get really crazy
foreign
took a lot of work there
still not out of danger
oh this could be a long game
this could be a very long game
foreign
foreign
there we go
foreign
foreign
oh man
yeah Rook Rook vs Bishop isn't so easy
to defend uh in
like with one second increment
what a game
that's how you win with the staffer
Gambit
almost 100 moves
thank you banana peel
wait is the sound working again
no it's not working
oh oh no my sound
yeah this line
um I mean white played really well like
there's about four it's technically one
refutation
um I'm pretty sure this this was my
analysis at least this was my conclusion
that like it gives black some practical
chances it's to sack the knights
um and then there's actually a funny
line like if King G1 here if here I
think taking
like takes Ono my queen but then check
maybe it's not quite the sign
I mean engine should say like plus five
for white
yeah
okay final game
oh yeah that was probably one of the
last games of the round
playing Grand Master
from Brazil
oh this is my second Grand Master
from Brazil this tournament
the first one was Creek or
okay Joe Bava London time
good luck Eric have a good night
exterminate
you real elements again apologies for
the
distorted audio
yeah we have a um
one of these lines
London
always nice when the pawn starts
thinking on move six
so A6
that's playable
I think I've looked at this recently
like Queen A5 Queen D2 takes it's a
little bit different than the like other
trappy line
because the queen can go back to A7 but
I remember looking at this I thought
it's good for white somehow
I definitely had a game in this like not
too long ago I think it was on Lee chess
but maybe I could have been title
Tuesday
I remember studying this line with
engine too but I don't remember the
conclusion
I just know that this is an idea
uh Knight C6 might be playable Knight
ft7 wow
so I could take on D5 now
and it looks risky for both sides
my queen is kind of a Target in the
center but I mean look at Black's Queen
like if F6 I almost trapped the queen
like there's a really funny line to take
take and then
Bishop D4 B6 I take
like I really want to sack the queen
here
I just sacked the queen for two Bishops
I mean I don't I mean queen E4 is just
so simple but Zack and the queen for two
Bishops
oh Life Choices let's talk the queen oh
no my queen
oh it looks so much fun
I take the bishop
that move I didn't see
at least I win this
so how bad or how good is this
yeah how good is this I have two Bishops
but opponent has a queen
okay Rook F3
oh no ah I allowed that move
wait a minute can I suck a rook
Rook G3
Rook G3 Queen H1 okay the very least
bishopath one
but at the very most King D2 oh no my
rook and then Bishop here
it's so close to mate Bishop H7
18 months so I am twins now I guess
I'm taking time here because I need to
figure out
to take
I mean Bishop F1
sick
I don't have much time
I trapped The Rook in the end
okay let's just go for it wait let's
start with King D2
I do have Bishop
I have this move
oh what a funny position
I'd work after oh I should have
considered Rook F3
there's B4 to consider as well
start with Rook F3
hmm
am I getting needed
foreign
why is my mouse
somehow my mouse settings changed
else is like super sensitive
no my time
my serve didn't reach the server
or my move didn't Reach This Server
I couldn't like I pressed some funny
button on my mouse and it's like it's so
easy to like over slip or under slip
ah that was such a funny line I'm sure
like I'm sure why it was just I should
have played Queen E4 like
Queen takes E6 is not so bad for white
though
yeah this position is better for white
it was such a funny line
uh there's probably some perpetual
like Rook F3 yeah I missed Rook F3
King ji Bishop seven
and then Rook yeah Rook G3 I probably
would have found
Rook G3 is a funny perpetual
it's crazy White's not meeting with two
Bishops and The Rook
this is my mouse
what do I do to fix it
there's so many buns on it
oops that's a back button
ah okay I think I fixed it
it was you're off the show
it was a bun like next to the scroll
wheel
as one of those buttons so there's two
buttons there
usually it's on the left side but
I think I've configured it improperly
anyway I gotta go
I gotta go um thanks everyone for
watching